it seems like a lot of your brand and a
lot of your popularity is linked to the
fact that you're a very
big advocate of personal responsibility
from from the shows that i've seen
a lot of what happens people come in
they don't want to take responsibility
for what's going on in their life they
don't want to take responsibility for
their choices and you you kind of tell
them
that they need to take responsibility
for those choices do you think that
that's
has that been successful typically i
mean it sounds like you have follow-up
resources and also have you gotten
blowback for for
pushing that hard on sort of the
personal responsibility angle well
look um i don't make the rules i'm just
telling them what they are
i mean look there are some things that
i'm one of those people that believes
old sayings get to be old sayings
because they're profound like a stitch
in time stage nine
you know i mean these things stick
around generation to generation
generation
because they apply and i have certain
rules like
you just don't reward bad behavior
i mean last he can figure this out you
don't need to come to me for that but
sometimes they're so close to it they do
you don't reward bad behavior if
somebody comes in they says i got a 30
year old son
that's on drugs he's living in my house
he's telling me i'm a she won't clean up
his room
and i can't get him to do what i need
him to do well
why are you letting him live with you
why are you
buying him a new cell phone why are you
paying all of this car payment and
insurance
and he's calling you
i mean to me that just seems simple
you're rewarding bad behavior and then
you're asking me why he does it why
wouldn't he do it
you're requiring nothing of him so of
course he's he's going to do that
you're you know some words get so
overused they lose their meaning like
enabling you say oh well you're an
enabler
people don't really stop and think what
that really means it's used so much it
loses this meaning
enable means i'm making it possible for
him to do what he's doing
and if i stop making it easy for him to
do what he's doing
then again old saying necessity is the
mother of invention
if he has to find a new way to live
then he'll find a new way to live i mean
so i i think sometimes when
i i'll i'll set a parent down
and say look let's face it
you're doing what you're doing
to make yourself feel better
not to make your attic child healthier
because it's not making your attic child
healthier
you're actually doing this so you're not
anxious about them being on the street
so don't kid yourself you're doing this
to help them
you're doing this so you don't lay awake
at night
you would rather enable them and have
them high in their bedroom
than worry about them being on the
street so you're doing this for you not
them you're being selfish
and you're crippling them at their
expense to make yourself feel better now
they don't want to hear that but is
there any other way to see it
and so i tell them the truth and usually
once they wrap their head around that
then they say i never thought of it that
way
and they change what they're doing i'm
not sure this is really a political
question as much as it is a societal
values question
and they have some political
ramifications it seems like we live in a
time where a lot of folks
want to blame their personal behavior on
forces beyond their control they want to
say that
that choices that are obviously within
their control are obviously
not within their control they're the
result of historical forces or forces
out there in the ether or institutional
pressures
or or all the rest do you see that
conflict right now in the country
between
between sort of an ethos of personal
responsibility and
and a system of thought that says that
you're really a victim of circumstance i
do but i don't think that
it is all or none um
and i look at it that way
i can use genetics as a good example um
my father was a bad alcoholic i mean
really bad alcoholic
i mean um he would
drink to the point of blackout oblivion
violence tearing up the house attacking
family members etc etc now
i am genetically predisposed
to be an alcoholic that doesn't
genetics oftentimes don't tell you who
is going to be
a certain way it just tells you who
is more likely to be a certain way it
just means for me
i have a steeper hill to climb it just
means for me that i have a bigger
challenge
because of historical events
learning history it nature nurture
controversy for me it was both that was
my modeling
from the most powerful role model in my
life which was my father
genetics because my father had the gene
and passed it on to me
so do i have a history that predisposes
me to a certain thing
yes the choice is still mine
i still have to make that choice and i
can still make the choice
i haven't had a drink in over 50 years i
made the choice
was it harder for me to make than
somebody that wasn't genetically
predisposed yes it was harder for me but
i still have to make it
and if you have a a historical precedent
that puts you at a disadvantage
okay i can understand that argument that
just means it's harder for you to do
what you need to do but it is still
up to you because you can not even god
can change what has happened
the past is over the future hasn't
happened yet the only time is right now
and the only question is what are you
going to do
and i'll say that i said this yesterday
there was a young woman
that i i was working with that had been
sexually molested
and she was feeling really guilty and
damaged by it
and i said to her let me be clear you
have
zero accountability for what happened to
you when you were eight and nine years
old
zero don't feel guilty i don't even care
if you think back
and think i actually enjoyed it
sometimes
and so you're thinking that makes me
different i feel guilty
you have zero accountability for what
happened to you when you were eight or
nine
you have 100 accountability for what you
do about it now
as an adult you are responsible for what
you do about it
is it fair that you have to be
responsible for it now that you have to
overcome that no it's not fair it just
is